Venice slowly is gliding back to life
for the moment this is a tourist center
with no tourists but Italy is easing its
lock down from today's shops and
restaurants will open again as long as
they stick to strict rules on social
distancing Venice's residents the first
to enjoy coffee in the sunshine isn't
mark square italy's been in lockdown for
10 weeks the scarring left by corona
virus has been horrific but now here in
Rome as across Europe there is a desire
to return to something like normal life
today we try to reopen the bar hoping
that customers will come for us there's
a problem because we used to work a lot
with tourism so at this moment it will
seem like a light reopening it's fine
for the employees and the shops but I
think we will miss tourism we'll see how
it goes in Brussels hairdressing salons
reopened after two months staff wear
protective equipment customers have to
wear a mask
gowns and surfaces are disinfected a lot
of planning has gone into how to open
safely so we have to be well organized
to make sure that we clean everything
each client's they came in the salon so
yeah it's it's our first day and very
strange but yeah something new in the
Belgian capital shops are now allowed to
open but customers are wary the streets
here are quieter than normal but this
simple act getting your haircut feels
like a hint of familiar everyday life
for many people this won't be about just
having a haircut in getting your unruly
lock down locks claimed instead it's
about doing the sort of things that we
actually take for granted about taking
the first step on a long path back to a
normal life in Athens the acropolis is
open to archaeologists son a smattering
of tourists the Greek economy so
dependent on tourism will be charred by
the impact of this virus
here and across Europe the economic
damage could be devastating today the
final touches were being applied to a
European rescue package running to
hundreds of billions of euros announced
by France and Germany but actually
bankrolled by the entire EU it is a vast
sum but such is the extent of the
economic damage people are already
asking if it will be enough
Adam Parsons Sky News Brussels